so when something like personal genomics
or synthetic biology happen suddenly
appears it seems to suddenly appear we
might have been working on for 30 years
but it seems to come out of nowhere then
you need strategies for engaging a lot
of people in thinking about where where
it will be going in the next few months
or a few years the internet was such a
thing that came very quickly it seemed
even though some of the infrastructure
was built in 60s and the 70s people
would say what do you well I would
anybody want a computer and by nineteen
ninety three in one year it went from
zero websites too many millions and the
same thing but there in unintended
consequences that weren't fully
articulated to the broad public probably
should have been for internet so for
example cyberstalking identity theft
addiction to computers hackers spam and
so forth these weren't really not
fleshed out they just said you know
something good will come with this right
a lot of good things did same thing with
personal genomics we need to figure out
how you're going to actually make it
useful which means you need to be able
people need to think about how they're
going to share the information with
other people are they going to be scared
of it not not want to know it themselves
are they going to be want to know it
themselves but not share it with anybody
and therefore not really know it they
have this big pile of Jesus season
season if they don't share it with
anybody they won't learn about it and so
you need we need to pursue this this
this this minefield and find ways that
people can feel safe about sharing at
least in a research sense so that's one
thing that was kind of an ethical legal
social issue that we've been we've been
working with in the Personal Genome
Project very proactively and then
synthetic biology our technology and
others create a situation where people
could synthesize
organisms either new or old old things
like smallpox which we thought was
extinct and not available to anybody
because it's available informations
available they can recreate it it's not
sufficient for all the good guys to say
we will be good guys you need to
actually have an active surveillance
mechanism where you're looking to see
people they're doing things that we're
either they don't know what they're
doing don't fully appreciate what
they're doing where they're actively
being terrorists type